[musique]
Et
développer des guerres, j'ai été choqué et non
savait quoi faire et est venu me voir honnêtement
parler dans ma tête la pensée que je peux
partir parce que je n'ai même pas essayé ça
pensé à moi-même parce que j'ai aussi
beaucoup de choses à la maison et
Je veux dire, je ne pensais même pas que je
Je peux partir mais le deuxième jour j'ai réalisé
que se passe-t-il que la seule chose qui me fait
Moscou garde cette chose
ressentir un très grand soulagement. je
quand je suis venu ici, j'ai réalisé qu'elle
juste un énorme poids enlevé de mes épaules et
Je suis maintenant horrifié par ce
qui se passe en russie maidan jouer avec moi
le
dortoir mai fini m disons la fin de la bataille
adresse du kit du site de la plate-forme cyclones
là comme je vais rester au travail ici alors
tous avec accès à l'Espagne arrive à
je vais finir fou
mot
[musique]
où puis-je quitter la russie sans visa
le plus populaire est l'arménie géorgie et
Turquie
Mais
ils sont tout pour moi
légèrement repoussant en raison de la culture
code
c'est-à-dire que la proximité est très importante pour moi
mentalité
[musique]
bête leur adresse i agression sommes sur le test
fascistes américains et europe de l'ouest il
adresses et dans le script Cyril de Rus
est venu ici est venu pas karachi juste ti
tel que
nous attendons que Vlad ait un cadeau ukrainien
capitula donner quoi mais
ces doudounes de l'ouest ont besoin d'armes plus tard
alors c'est sur un autre vide
[musique]